bonjour que si elle ruine merci de
répondre avec nous à nos questions sur
rt france tout d'abord comment est-ce
que vous expliquer ces phénomènes de
violence envers ces personnes dont la
vocation est de nous protéger
on connais très bien d'un problème de la
violence entre les établissements et les
professionnels de santé dans les zones
de conflit mais c'était vraiment pendant
la pandémie qui a mis en évidence que
cette violence peut c'est également
éclaté dans le pays quand on considère
pas vraiment en conflit et jeux fra
c'est vraiment pendant les périodes de
forte tension quand il ya un nouveau
confinement était imposé où il y a des
les hôpitaux sont débordés et cette
frustration peut se montrer en violences
contre les professionnels de santé
est ce que vous avez peur que ce
phénomène se maintiennent voire
s'accentuent à vers le avec le temps où
est-ce que c'est uniquement dû à la
pandémie
la question des paris nation c'est bien
que dans l'est dans certains pays il ya
aussi la violence contre les programmes
des partis nation donc je ferai ça peut
aussi continuer pendant ces périodes où
on essaie de parler la population
mondiale
quelles sont les zones les plus touchées
dans le monde puisque c'est un document
mondiale
quelles sont les zones les plus touchées
et quid de la france exactement
donc on distingue les filles ils sont
touchés par la violence liée au conflit
et aussi des les autres pays qui sont ou
étaient la pandémie qui a vraiment
déclenché la violence contre les
personnels de la santé et en ce qui
concerne des pays qui étaient vraiment
les cris touché par la violence qui
confier par la pandémie c'était l'inde
et l'amex limbé pardon et la mexique
l'inde et le mexique et la france alors
ouest qu'elle se situe on sait pas
exactement ce sens concernant la france
on a une sondage qui est effectué par
l'ats ils ont quelques informations qui
était celui par les infirmières surtout
en france mais on sait pas exactement
les endroits où ça les violences et a
dépassé
quel serait selon vous les solutions
pour lutter contre ces actes de violence
il faut vraiment qu'on améliorer la
prévention pour que ça sera pas les
médecins les infirmières qui cela la
frustration des populations a émis quand
vous parlez de prévention ça veut dire
quoi c'est travailler sur les mentalités
comment est-ce qu'on change les
mentalités
c'est un petit peu ça c'est aussi
surtout la communication pour bien
expliquer comment un poids il faut
prendre quelques mesures sanitaires et
pour quad on peut pas voir des gens qui
sont hospitalisés par exemple dans le
passé surtout la communication et de
bien expliquer comment et pourquoi pas
aider la promotion
comment justement est-ce que vous jugez
les communications des différents
gouvernements par rapport à ça c'est
insuffisant selon vous cela-dit pont
donc c'est une question de communication
des gouvernements mais c'est aussi une
question comment on peut aider le
personnel
de santé de vraiment communication en
situation où il y aller les familles qui
vous avoir des informations
c'est vraiment la communication ont tous
les niveaux et de toutes autres
gouvernements mais aussi dans les
situations direct dans les hôpitaux sur
titres merci beaucoup
christine havel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice d'insight d'une security
insight